okay and what actually before I get to
before we get to the first question from
the audience there's actually somebody
really happy submitted a question so one
of the interesting things is that across
all of your work and all your
presentations is that it's unsurprising
but it's very reassuring that the minute
you start talking about programmable
material what most of you brought up is
the people who are doing the programming
which is you know the the users right
that it's not it's not just about making
some abstract open system it has users
at the end of it and and and that
there's a certain intention and delight
in thinking about who those are but I
guess one of my question is when you're
designing for those types of systems you
know do you start with the user do you
start with the uses or is it or is it
the system like you know where where
does where do you begin in designing a
system that has communities and users in
it I mean we started selfishly to make
something that we needed to use for our
own work yep and then made it modular
enough that people could expand it for
and you know empowering people to follow
their own desires so we didn't I didn't
need to be
you know fabricating objects but other
people did so I was ending the modular
system they were able to make libraries
for fabricating objects that like build
on top of the initial work we did so
it's really I think the I think it's
important to be a domain expert in the
area that you're working in and nobody
is a domain expert in every area so I
think the modularity of the system was
what was really key and also I think
just in terms of how you share things
being important so you built something
the next most important thing to do is
then send that out to other people who
are either going to build upon it react
to it whatever I think one of the really
terrific things in the last talk was
seeing these fab labs all over
how all over the place that are kind of
taking the ideas and kind of doing
different sorts of things with it and I
think that's kind of add that
multiplying effect is really you know
what will drive this this type of effort
one of the one of the things that was
interesting from the beginning Nikolas
said you know that the creators will be
the inventors and you know that relates
to the sketchbook idea and I think
across the panel a lot of a lot of
things we saw were how code became a new
sketchbook it became a new tool to
sketch and think about whatever it was
in a fast way
but the same thing were you know Nadia
with your work machines in some way
became like the sketchbook we could
quickly modularize and connect and adapt
and have these like machine sketchbooks
and then going beyond that I think like
the playfulness of the droplets or the
materials that I showed like I'm really
interested in how materials start to
become like a creative collaborator or
how the materials become a sketchbook
and so all of these are you know maybe
different users but also have different
agency in that creative exploration
whether it's code machines or materials
one of the things that I'm really
interested in across this question is
how how tools scale into systems where
it's not just one user at a time but
where the system aggregates users to
produce emergent effects that are beyond
what anyone intentionally intentionally
of any one user and one way we think
about that transformations as platforms
which are sort of I guess going against
loves original point their way in which
what may a sort of a range of variables
is made into a particular set of
constants that are fixed like a ribbon
grid upon which things may grow you know
what and learn infinitely well and I
think and I think part processing is
work this way and this is well and so I
think some of these questions me around
them you know there's also probably
something to be said
considering the interdisciplinarity of
this this group on the polyvalence of
this term of the trim program there's
obviously a software program of this
internship but architecture of course is
interested in the question of program on
the modeling of this as well
political program connectivity works as
well and I think part of the way we're
going to think about this transition
from tool to tool the platform is one
that transverses each of these I mean in
terms of some of our work with full
scope the idea of community is central
because you can never predict or
anticipate what users would do and so I
mean on one hand we have community
health workers or using these tools and
on the other hand you have kids who want
to understand what glitter is and you'd
let them run and I think you all that
feedback comes back and from day one I
mean as a tool maker I think it's very
clear to people who make - but it's the
it's the users broadly that will define
what that tool will be known for whether
you like it or not right yeah but it's
just essentially thing that you can't
really imagine you can't really imagine
the user and yet you have to design for
them yeah that's what all of these are
four or five years - ten years of work
that goes in into coming to where they
are all kinds of false starts and yeah I
think having having different feedback
systems at different scales as well so
running workshops and in small groups
and getting that immediate feedback and
then having putting as much time and
effort into the community and the social
component finding a balance between the
technology innovation and development
and the social components but having a
kind of a six channel for being able to
understand what's happening is so
important I think it's one of the major
shift in terms of how how people who
design and create things think about
their work which is that it used to be
that the day that you released it that
you ship it you're done and you and you
you know you go to sleep or you get
drunker you do whatever it is you do to
celebrate the fact that something is
done and it's a day of releasing
something with basically all the work
that you guys are talking about is to
like that's it's it's the least
important day right it's just did it
that's that's that's actually where
things begin and I think that's why the
drinking begins so
difficult also I think something to be
said they're also for infrastructure and
maintenance of platforms like this you
know the processing now has their
foundation and and and these are like
infrastructures that then come into
place sort of arbitrarily like yes I
also was a user who was frustrated about
how machines were designed and made and
so I made some kind of platform systems
that could scale better because I wanted
it and then but then going forward how
do you how you have that be maintainable
how is that going to continue and know
if if people don't become members of
processing you know what's going to
happen we're going to have to move on to
something else and and for certain
things I think the way that
infrastructure has grown traditionally
like maybe through the internet the w3c
and places like that it's just the sort
of hippie idea of neoliberalism that
yeah we can all do this you know we're
self-sufficient people who like need
infrastructure and applications and
we're going to make both of them but as
you know as Benjamin's talk definitely
pointed out the world becomes a more
complicated space and things are a lot
more complex than maybe they were in the
early when Nicholas was still Nicky eyes
like that Jenna how are those
infrastructure is still going to be
maintained and state interoperable and
and also be inclusive and accessible and
that's something that I don't know this
I don't think that this panel and body
is very well at all like the we're all
bunch of people with a bunch of MIT
affiliation this would time its mere
elite institution and so maybe
everything the work that we look at
looks really democratic and inclusive
but it's also sort of not and how is
that going to scale one thing about
materials for me is
[Music]
in some ways like going back to the
physics of computation are going back to
materials for me becomes more
democratized because we all live and
experience and build and can see things
and feel things and touch things and so
I'm really interested in how we bring
like electronics and code back to the
physical and allow us to play again and
allow us to experiment and physically
make whether that's making machines or
playing with materials or pushing on
them or activating them in the same
sophisticated way that you know groups
could do with code but it's much more
difficult to able to do that I mean it
took processing and Ben and Kasey a lot
of effort a lot of time to try to bring
it to a language that anyone can use and
it's still super challenging to do that
but you know anyone can pick up Lego and
snap these things together anyone could
learn about logic or sensors or
actuators through a material on a desk
that's moving and so there's something
inspiring about that about the
democratization of information in
materials all right um I was going to
say they it's also part of where the you
know pedagogy side of what we were doing
at MIT came from lo2 is that um it's not
that interesting to have a handful of
people at MIT who can build this stuff
it gets a lot more interesting if you
actually you know get it out there and
push it out there that part of that also
came from you know so John my adviser oh
you know one of the things that his
advisors when he was doing his PhD and
designed in Japan would say to him was
well that's great you're doing all these
you know complex technical things and
you're doing code and design and all
that but who else is doing it
so you don't have any peers and you
don't have anybody else by which you can
actually compare this work and you know
so you need to actually go out there and
get other people kind of creating these
things so we can even think about them
and evaluate them and you know it's just
not that compelling if you know again
the people who are already drawn to it
are going to find their way into it but
rather have you know expanding that
audience being so important
I just wanted to say that I think it's
fairly point about the making the tools
at the point of accesses to the platform
as a gala tearing as possible and
building them on experiences that are
points of access that we have in common
or experiences we have in common is
extremely important and I see but I see
that in a way as a sort of the same that
there's still the question of as tool
scales in the platform and as increased
as software eats the world more and more
of the world that's platform scales into
what is an essence of governing
apparatus as much as a technical
apparatus of its then the question that
nothing it goes against your point but
just it to echo an audience point it
becomes questions of questions of power
questions of interest become inevitable
and while I see those also as design
problems I don't see them necessarily as
engineering problems in the conventional
way and so but it's not a wish to say
that these precisely why this
conversation should need to amplify so
there's a question here is from Carol
Jones who says I liked Casey's phrase
aesthetics of computing is there medium
specificity and software generated forms
is there a trope towards iteration and
or symmetry
I think there's and within that there
are all these larger questions about the
the aesthetics that are produced when we
build these kinds of systems the name
comes from Donna ADA in his research
group at the Media Lab which started in
97 it was called the aesthetics and
computation group and so that group
existed until 2003
I've always been baffled by the name
I've never heard a clear explanation of
what you I think that there's there is
this sense of of an aesthetics of
computation which is clean and uses like
Platonic solids and you know basic forms
and shapes and it's very inhuman I think
that a lot of languages and tools make
it easy to make things like that but I
mean one thing I've learned through
teaching
over the years is that there are so many
other ways of doing things like the
students that I that I'm teaching
they're not interested in computation
they're interested in sort of using
computation for furthering their own
vision or none of them work so they're
photographers they're animators they
want to make games they're book makers
and so they make things that are
radically different from anything I've
ever made and I think they've really
proven to me that there there is no
aesthetics of computation but the tools
are biased and weighted too I think and
so a lot of the first things people make
undergraduate work workshop work it does
seem to have a certain aesthetic but
I've really been working hard to promote
projects that are of a different style
come from a different in tubs framework
of different ways of thinking and I've
noticed that you know whether that's
code or a milling machine or a laser
cutter or 3d printer it's almost the
same as like giving a kid crayon or
eventually a pencil or you know
watercolors or clay or whatever it is in
the beginning they will likely make the
things that you would normally make with
the pen or the pencil or the watercolor
and they'll make a mess and then it'll
you know and then they'll find it but
over time I think two things happen one
is that you upgrade your tools and you
then look for new tools or make your
tool which is really interesting and
then the second is that the project
becomes more important than the tool and
I think that's where you're getting at
and the aesthetic stops looking like the
bias of the tool and starts to look like
the authorship and the interest in the
curiosity and the weirdness of what you
want to do and that's really what we
want to get to that it's not about the
tool anymore in the beginning we're
excited about that but eventually it's
like your own the concept is more
important I mean I think this is a very
important point which starts to
piggyback on what Nadia had said about
where is the democratization right here
it's I mean people do these things not
just for fun but because there is also a
deep need and most of the time I mean
when you talk about projects that have a
kind of a healthcare context or even an
environmental context a biodiversity
context it starts to happen where very
clearly one
they have explored the territory the
project takes over and they build a
community around that and they own that
question I mean so many times the goal
of at least the types of tools we think
about is to make them as open and it as
possible like a window but then what you
look through it to see is really defined
by the community and that is almost
essentially the ideal way to do this
would be to really pass the ownership
the ownership really belongs to the
community and in that somewhere there is
a democratization and I think if you
don't realize this fast enough on the
project side is that you know this is
only a tools are only conduit to the
bigger incredibly hard no of course
there's why we do it right I mean it's
just that maintaining open and
participatory access in a system that
has to make oh hell the city yeah no
it's hard yeah I'm not saying that's the
answer but I think that's why we do this
because there's an interesting research
question maybe like how can you maintain
a system that stays open and in
consensus-based or at least somehow
furthers best practices without
reenacting via well you know we made up
this system or it was great if you want
to deport to javascript program or how
code affects no effect there may be an
asymmetry it means it is important
security code I think I just say one
more thing about that former question I
think that um there's moments when
formal material exploration is is is a
good thing and I'm thinking back to like
since we talked a little bit about the
Bauhaus earlier today like when
moholy-nagy like went to the Bauhaus and
kind of took it from a craft based
education into working with industrial
materials working with metals and then
later with plastics I think that that
was a necessary kind of experimentation
I think the idea of the aesthetics of
computation was that there was a period
in the 90s where we needed to explore
the medium and we should need to see
what it could do and what it was capable
of for me personally I went through that
period but now I mean I love the feeling
that work needs to be more based in a
strong social point of view or a strong
political point of view
and that really I think that one maybe
evolved into the other or or it just
takes a little bit of time for to grow
into the other evidently we only have
like another minute or so so um and
there's a lot of questions but instead
I'm just going to I'm going to ask one
which I was thinking about is I was
listening to you all which is so as as
computation basically starts to very
deliberately shape the physical world
around us in all of your work and
investigations I mean would you
characterize it more as are we
discovering something about physical
material and behavior etcetera that
we're lifting up or are we imposing a
computational model of the world down
into matter or both or neither in other
words you know are we - are we taking a
world view and trying to push it into
material are we trying to understand
something about and when I say material
I mean also life because that was
referred to in many presentations you
know are we are we are we are we lifting
up a worldview are we imposing a
worldview what's what's happening like
what is happening as the assumption
there that there's like somehow the
world and us and that we do not
constitute the world and that what we're
making and as we're making isn't also
being and vice versa and so I think the
question presupposes the answer where
you say yeah I'm creating a system in
which this is this certain kind of
framework can be used but the assumption
there is that the system also doesn't
affect you and vice versa so I I agree
with I again at their point with with
with not with money's point about the
being and the being in the world eyes
which are part of the argument I was
trying to make at the same time the
there is always a distal knology built
into the tools and the procedures by
which we would use and project these in
a certain way I thought on my answer we
definitely need both I think part of
this the prep that we've discovered
computation as much as we've invented in
this regard work to show but I also see
it as something may be a path towards
what
paradigm that comes next the next
machine after computation there being
something that we get to closer to this
it may have more to do with what
Nicholas's group of biotech us and your
digital is opposed to the other way
around which is where we're at now I
sort of see it as both right like yes
longhand we in order to solve you know
more complex difficult problems we tend
to throw more money in Michigan machines
and more complexity so you get more with
more and I think over time you start to
question that and think you know maybe
we could do more with less and we can
start to take out the devices take out
the computer take out the actuator - and
you're only left with material that has
all the agency of all the complex robot
computers we had before and now it's the
simple dumb thing that has all these
awesome features so that's kind of
trying to simplify over time and the
other one is that we're discovering new
things and whether that's synthetic
biology or material science or you know
manu's amazing work you know we're
discovering amazing new things with a
new kind of lens of elegance
looking at it and I think those two are
coming together in order to create this
new perspective on matter I mean I think
just to add to this one important aspect
while doing all this work is to realize
that our viewpoint of computation has
been based on the history of so physics
of computation in general or if you were
to like you know the best computer
that's out there right now is our brain
what do we actually know about its modes
and models and yes we have theories and
ideas and fantastic ideas but can
somebody singularly say and so you know
you just have to be open to discovering
and ironically we have also had a sort
of fascination with far more complex
biological problems where we forgot a
little bit to the fact that a single
cell is a remarkable machine and that
now is coming up and so I think there's
so much to learn that it would be silly
to take our models and impose it
although if you don't do that right you
know you're not making progress so yeah
I think yeah you have to keep an open
mind
all right well let me thank all of you
for not just representations if your
amazing work thanks very much